so we got the Democrats with the Border
crisis economic crisis we got the mass
Exodus from the workforce we got Israel
Palestine Democrats trying to roll
what's the next big thing Democrats have
been calling for Hillary Clinton gave an
interview about a week ago where she
said it's time for to hold these big
tech companies accountable for
disinformation and I'm like okay but
she's not talking about random
conspiracy Nutters she's talking about
us she's talking about anyone who
challenges The Establishment narrative
because they might have their their you
know control of a bunch of different
areas of industry and they're destroying
it but what happens when people are able
to listen to this conversation that's a
problem because now people are going to
open their eyes they're gonna be able to
watch and which brings me to the next
story they're being radicalized here's
the story from louder with Crowder
YouTube has suspended later with Crowder
again applies second hard strike on
Crowder's Channel and a strike on their
Crowder bits Channel which is segments
from the from Crowder's show so that
means though the one strike is less
relevant compared to the two strikes
once you get two strikes you can't
upload or stream or post anything for
two weeks on any channel
you're supposed to be able to but we
know they are doing after Crowder with a
warning for trying to explain that he
got a strike can't do that one more
strike in Crowder is permanently banned
what's the hard strike mean it means
like they could take your content down
and say we've removed your content but
not issued a strike for these reasons
that which they should do they should do
because this this shows what they're
doing to Crowder that their main goal is
literally just to get Crowder banned and
justify it in the Press
they're claiming that by by Crowders
supporting law enforcement action they
were cheering on death or tragedy and
it's like wait hold on if the cops are
doing what cops are legally supposed to
do and you cheer for that isn't what
we're supposed to do or are we supposed
to cheer for Lawless activity that's a
problem I don't know the details on what
he said or how he said it but I do know
that they have had a Target on him and
anyone else and you know they're going
to pick them off one one at a time I
guess so Crowder pulled up a bunch of
examples of targeted harassment on
YouTube that's fine the Covington kids
is a huge example of tons of people who
got away with it and they're clearly
just going after Crowder The Cliffs are
going to erode
look I don't know maybe maybe the
crowded people don't want to hear it
when I say it but I think they are
gearing up to Nuke crowd what happens is
as an admin I was an admin at mines for
like five six years or something so from
my perspective as an admin you when you
start to see users that you start to
resent because they do so much stuff
that makes you make decisions about is
this a violation or is it not and you
have to like constantly be thinking
about it and stressing about it and then
you start to resent the person and
that's what's happening these people
there are admins that resent him and are
looking for reasons to destroy him maybe
but they're also heavily targeted by
Media Matters you Google Search Stephen
Crowder and it's all basically Media
Matters articles and I think a lot of it
what it is is there I don't think it's
personal necessarily I think that
there's people at Google who are just
like we are getting slammed by Media
Matters
so just err on the side of it's a strike
don't give them the benefit of the doubt
what should happen they were talking
about Makaya Bryant what a knife was a
stab a woman and they said sorry it's
Justified that's the way cookie crumbles
or whatever and they said that was
glorifying death or something what
should have happened is they should have
sent a message saying we've taken
another video with no strike to inform
you that this is not acceptable for
future reference that's it that's
considered like a soft a soft strike is
when they take the I mean people would
just call it yeah like a strike from the
channel or like a removal or whatever
and I don't think they should have
either way I'm just saying if they were
actually concerned about Crowder's like
demeanor or attitude they would have
taken it down and said we're not giving
you a strike but you can't do that all
right a hard strike is basically like
it's supposed to be when like a person
gets naked on camera well actually I
think you do that you get a permanently
ban you get permanently banned if you
like just like go crazy but there are
some channels that have exemptions for
for showing nudity and stuff if it's
science related but like strikes are
supposed to be you spout a bunch of
racist stuff and you're angry and young
at the camera and they go yo boom gone
strike you can't do that don't do it
again Crowder was like an officer came
here's what they did well that's the law
that's what happens and YouTube was like
strike yeah based on the get well I
don't want to set myself up for anything
but I can't believe that I have no
issues uh in comparison to an issue like
that that makes it very clear by getting
strikes yeah I mean uh I yeah I mean I'm
backing out of this conversation not to
draw any attention to my content in
particular but it does seem to me that
that is an overreach and it's a it's
part of their overall plan which is how
do we get rid of crowder it's not like
it's not like enforcing their rules to
the letter of their rules same thing
with Alex Jones yeah it was very obvious
when they were going after Jones
especially with Sandy Hook stuff I'm
like dude I get it the guy said dumb
things but that was like eight years ago
and there and they keep bringing it up
and I'm like it's the weirdest thing
that's what they what they bring up
every time
and it was interesting to see it was
coordinated with every major Network
taking him out at the same time they
didn't like him for his political
message does he say you know outrageous
things oh definitely yeah we got we got
we got we got content removed on on this
show because of things he said because
they don't like him even though they're
like no it's fun you can have them on
the show and then there are certain
people that they will just try and get
rid of and they will not give the
benefit of it out to so the problem is
technically we all work for YouTube
because they're the boss they could fire
you whenever they want which is why we
set up timcast.com so that way they
can't fire us they can kick us off the
platform now but not terminate our our
positions so the truth is though
if Crowder gets nuked people aren't
going to leave YouTube they're not going
to do it Joe Rogan left YouTube for
Spotify and this in my opinion was smart
um first of all you know he got paid out
good for him but it also means that he's
actually safer in a lot of ways I know
there was this attempt on Spotify by
employees to get him banned and then
there were some episodes that got
removed but it's a contract where
Spotify knows what they bought into and
so
Joe was allowed to say things he can't
say on YouTube tons of things he stops
to be careful because Media Matters goes
after him and we know that companies are
suckling the teeth of Media Matters
desperately terrified of them because
they're pathetic spineless losers Media
Matters or the companies Media Matters
the companies are they're both
um but but Rogan still has it's it's
different he can't be banned out right
he can get criticized he can have to
apologize but not going to strike his
content remove him or things like that
so the problem is people didn't go
follow him a lot of people did but a lot
of people didn't and a lot of people I
have said like oh you know I'll watch
his Clips I don't watch the main show
anymore
I haven't watched or listened to a
single Joe Rogan episode since he went
to Spotify I've listened to one me too I
just got it last week bill was like you
got to get the new one with the the uh
the military guy that was talking about
aliens UFOs legit dude I listen I
listened to one in the sauna how was it
uh we we turned it on it was it was it
was good it was it was classic Joe Rogan
but it's it's not easy you know like I
go on YouTube you know for for more than
just podcasts vodcast videos whatever
and Joe's on Spotify and it's not an app
I use so it's just like out of sight out
of mind it's free
um and the stock of Spotify shot up like
after they paid Rogan his millions
however many it was hundreds of millions
or 100 million um yeah their stock went
up like billions and billions of dollars
the value of the company what a move so
because that Joe got underpaid then
but you know I mean 100 million dollars
and he's free I know but at the market
says very specifically that this 100
million dollar acquisition translates to
whatever how many billions of dollars a
month
this is why I think you know I'm a very
different person from Joe for instance
I would have just started a podcast
Network I would have created an app I
would have created the podcast Show app
and I would have announced we're going
to be signing podcasts to this network
and it would just take over it would
Dominate and then that's it and you know
you know what I would do I would tell
the big networks you can plug in to our
feed you know and it's gonna like you
know work out some deal some cash deal
and then people I'll tell you this if
Joe said he was going to launch his own
podcast app and then he went to a bunch
of top podcasters and says how would you
like to be the first 10 podcasts on my
app they'd be like
sign me up bro what do I got to do
because people would go to his app it
might not be the same as he he's
definitely going to get more viewers
than Spotify because I don't think
Spotify gave him audience he gave
Spotify audience and then imagine you
look at some of these other bigger
podcasts now their name gets appear
right next to Joe that would have kicked
it off and then Joe could have done a
deal with the other networks saying okay
you want to send a hitter content now
you got to pay us a a royalty fee but
he's already a wildly famous and Wealthy
guy who's done always want to do and or
you could just take 100 million dollars
does it keep talking to your buddies in
your basement exactly not too bad I
think it worked out for him I think he's
stoked he's like takes a lot of the heat
off his stuff is amazing he gets to hang
out and talk about things with less less
like I understand
um look I don't know if Joe wants to be
the biggest fish in the sea and that's
his goal but
I understand the the mentality of being
like I'd like to have less viewership
because this is too much because you you
you're a big Target everyone's coming
after you the bigger you are the harder
you fall Joe got 100 million dollars he
can hang out with his friends talk about
what he wants to for the most part and
he's probably like this is great I can
hang out with my friends and have
conversations and I got I don't got to
worry as much and he doesn't have an ISP
either breathing down his neck anymore
because he just uploads this video to
Spotify and it's all that's great
yeah pros and cons I think a lot of
people were upset because he was he was
a uh he is a very powerful figure in the
culture War but his position has
diminished since leaving you know iTunes
and YouTube and all that stuff to go
work for some silly Swedish company
Google
isn't Spotify they own Spotify I'm
pretty sure yeah alphabet really is it
Google or Apple yeah could you Google it
oh my God could you Google it oh my God
that's great Google should not be a verb
and verify I'm pretty sure yeah it's
owned by uh alphabet
so it's just from one company the next
what it is right
did you look it up it is Daniel Eck
co-founder yeah who owns it which
company alphabet I think it's alphabet
did you look it up sure
uh I'm pretty sure
that's so disturbing did you look it up
no I'm looking for it
did you search it's taking a long time
yeah just take a long time so Daniel act
yeah did he sell it anywho Joe Rogan's
on Spotify I'm not watching I'm on
Spotify in April of 2017. there you go
41 billion that's right 41. Google did
not buy it no they did I don't know man
where's the
who owns Spotify right now Daniel Eck no
it looks like they're not owned they
required it in 2019 Google slash why is
it so hard to find 43.4 billion four of
us live on the air trying to do one
Google search
oh my God shut up you dumb robot
freaking computer digital music news
Google alphabet acquiring Spotify and
43.4 billion dollar cash account but it
says acquiring did they actually acquire
it I think I don't know Act is only
worth four and a half billion so we're
merging three worlds a lot of people
mention that when when uh Joe switched
over
that it was it's like still a Google
property so what's the difference oh
yeah he got paid a bunch of money and he
could do his thing so look look look
look at what's gonna happen now
Joe left end of last you know mid last
year at some point Crowder is on the
verge of getting the ax
where we here at Tim cast IRL probably
not long for this world year or two so
it's like we got to build up timcast.com
and that's why I want to make it a
network we're gonna we're you know we
got a ton of work being on the website
in the back end we're we're doing
staging sites making sure it's done
right and we don't disrupt everything
once we get the new site up it'll be
amazing we're gonna have a newsroom
we're gonna have articles being put up
uh already I'm looking to commission
mini docs so you guys just got to send
us the mini doc ideas and Port your
portfolio show us show me some videos
you've made we're gonna just be like
here's your budget go to wherever and
film do what you can and then we'll
we're going to publish this stuff we're
gonna start making as much as we can
because uh we got to do it
with if Crowder goes Joe's already off
YouTube so he's you know it's less
likely to be seen and they've been
Banning people like crazy they're
pushing everything towards the CNN World
View
got us gotta gotta push back gotta stand
up I mean Crowder's got his website as
well he's got a lot of crowder he's got
mug Club so we gotta just build as much
as we can before we're all gone I saw
the Tim pool network was like the second
most viewed right wing YouTuber next to
Crowder where I don't know something on
Twitter right winger yes only by like
two million viewers or something this is
funny because there was a the guy who
did this I asked him like what makes my
channel right wing and he's like well
you're crazy Democrats all the time and
I was like so is Jimmy Dore but you put
him as left wing it's like well Jimmy's
very different I'm like when I I pulled
up Jimmy Jimmy Dore his YouTube and I
pulled up mine and we covered the exact
same things in the exact same way
and I was like so what makes my right
wing in his left and it's like I guess
Jimmy is like like more profoundly like
more directly left you know like he says
and I'm like
I'm sorry it's because of your guests
Tim no no this is this is not guess it's
my main Channel yeah oh so is it the red
letters
maybe that's an inside joke from
pre-show no no no no no no no it's the
the view of it people look at him like
well it looks Republican it looks
conservative or something and I'm like
is that it because I look at these
lefties who hate the Democrats and all
they do is write on Democrats all day
yeah that's it that's why it's funny too
and the presses are like Tim pools right
wing and I'm like why because you like
the Democrats it's the red letters you
tricked them all well the red letter is
just a regular psychology thing red
catches your attention I figured out
Google tried to buy Spotify the talks
didn't the talks broke down and now
spotify's own mainly by the CEO and
another guy so it's owned by the all
right so it didn't happen them Swedish
boys they got Rogan instead basically
worth more than 43 billion in their
opinion and they get to hold on the
company wow and it is because that
network is
man that's big I I fear that uh I'm
knocking the grill over I did sorry that
a lot of people are going to cash out
the moment they can of Spotify no no no
just of of the culture War
like I don't think Joe ever signed up to
be a prominent figure in the culture War
I know he's just he was talking about
the moon landing or something in
gorillas I don't know Bigfoot yeah and
then all of a sudden he starts talking
having interesting conversations and
then he starts you know getting in the
culture War because the culture war is
dominating and then all of a sudden he's
forced into this Fray he's probably like
dude I am out I don't want to be here
I'm a comedian you know for us like
we're more political cultural politics
hard politics it's a very different
space and uh I bet there's a lot of
people who are saying look there's I'm
not gonna name names but there are some
people who have been posting about this
recently that they used to make
political content and then were like
dude I never was into politics I don't
want to do this and they've bailed out
and they're doing non-political things
they're like I want to get away from
this going to video games going to
skateboarding whatever because it's
exhausting it's terrifying it's uh
alienating it is awful politics is
terrible
it's stressful it's full of anger and
hypocrisy and it makes you a Target
makes you a Target it puts you at risk
doesn't for most people it doesn't pay
very well thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time